Thank you.
Okay, we'll open up the committee conference.
On House bill 12.
Very much 1 of mine.
1236.
okay.
I'm in the right place.
um so, we have a little conversation here just to make sure and we understand all the pieces.
Obviously, in terms of the underlying bill, there was never any issue of the underlying bill for commerce.
We were, we would just had these other 2 things were added to it and they were money.
So that put me in a little bit of a panic without knowing anything about them.
I have now been educated that we don't want to have a force overtime on state employees, and it would make matters worse rather than better.
So that's why that was added to the bill.
Representative Leon had some concerns with it, and she is now feeling comfortable.
So I guess I'll do something I don't normally do, but is there anybody in the room has any problem with us concurring with this legislation?
Okay, so.
So, thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I would just say that the fiscal committee last week, I think it was last week, approved $5 million for the Community Mental Health Center.
So the part four of that is a request of the department.
It obviously does have $670,000 of fund in it, but it'll try to prevent the problem that came from the medicaid expansion unwind and a state law that requires continued treatment of mental health patients so that's what that piece is about i think mr monahan was here he and he brought it to us the department signed off on it um so it's i think well worth the expenditure okay so is everybody okay with this then okay so i'll make a motion that uh the house will see to the senate position um and on house bill 1236 period all those in favor please say aye aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so move unanimously.
Okay.
I will have that drawn up.
Thank you.
Okay.
All right, we have 15 minutes.
Thank you.
okay we'll um open up the uh committee conference on uh house bill 1633.
um so at this point i is we're going to the discussion will start on the house side and in terms of things that they want, because I'm going to run on the premise that the house is going to a seed to the Senate.
Version and now what we, we house members would like to request to it to to amend this bill with.
So I will will go around with this group here and I will start with my Democratic leader of the Commerce Committee and and you want to do what are the issues that you would like to see addressed in this bill and I guess we'll probably try to go wrong trying to you know where it is in the is in the bill so that when, if we do go forward, we know what we're, we're fixing at the time.
So.
Okay.
Thank you.
Um, what we would like to see for this in terms of, uh, the things that we would like to see is to decrease the decriminalization level to two ounces.
Um, this would allow for higher limits immediately while delaying the smoking in public and other penalties.
So where's that in the bill?
Do we know?
No, no.
I'm just telling you my...
Okay.
Just telling you the things that we'd like to see.
We think that that would be a cleaner solution than moving everything up to immediately.
We'd like to see the 12.5 tax fee and the Rosenwald Amendment for ATC preference.
And in terms of consuming from the passenger prohibitions, we'd like to remove medicinal edibles from that prohibition.
Those are our big four.
Okay.
Anything from...
Sure.
May I just turn it for a minute?
For discussion.
Sure.
minute uh sure thank you from um going back and listening to the floor debate from last week, I identified kind of 3 buckets of votes that need to be shifted from no to yes.
And this amendment represents addressing those 3 buckets.
So, the 1st piece here is just a clean up the no person shall smoke or vaporize while in a passenger or motor vehicle.
We can skip that for the moment.
The next section here refers to.
What my colleague was referencing with regard to the Rosenwald amendment.
I took what was the simplest and fewest possible words to add in order to address that concern.
If you'll see this refers to page 14 of the Senate version of the bill toward the bottom of the page.
And just adds first state of New Hampshire or second another state.
Okay.
Okay, and the second piece decreases the franchise fee.
From 15% to 12 and a half percent.
That you'll see from lines 14 to 17.
14 to 17.
And then the entire rest of this amendment refers to what my colleague mentioned as far as lowering the decrim limit from REST OF THIS AMENDMENT REFERS TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED AS FAR AS LOWERING THE DECRIM LIMIT FROM OR I GUESS RAISING IT FROM THREE QUARTER OUNCE TO TWO OUNCE.
What I found to be a large source of objection among House members was that they were looking forward to on day one legalizing up to two ounces and pulling the rug out from under that idea really took the wind out of the sails of being able to get it passed in the house so knowing that that was not going to be able to be moved i thought this was kind of a a way to give those members what they're looking for without changing the effective date of the legalization.
MR.
Yep.
So, I guess we're all set then?
Yeah.
Okay.
So yes, now it's balls in your court now.
So, uh, so again, online, um, you're basically saying it's okay if you have an edible, but the past, but they can't take and consume, which would impact.
Yes.
So what I had heard was that the intention of that section, which is found on page 7, line 11 of the Senate version of 1633, just removed the word consume.
so left smoke and vaporize as I understood this was the intention to not have you know secondhand smoke being ingested by the driver and then I thought more importantly THIS WAS THE INTENTION TO NOT HAVE, YOU KNOW, SECOND HAND SMOKE BEING INJESTED BY THE DRIVER.
AND THEN I THOUGHT MORE IMPORTANTLY, KEEPING THE STENCH OFF THE ROAD.
BECAUSE I NOTICED ESPECIALLY WHEN I'M RIDING AROUND ON MY MOTORCYCLE, CATCHING THOSE WAFTS AS I'M RIDING AROUND, IT KIND OF UPSETS MY DAY.
FURTHER QUESTION.
SO AGAIN, STARTING ON SECTION 8, THEN, THIS SECTION STRIKLY IS LOOK this section strictly is looking to give preference to any business in the hamster that's already doing cannabis first before giving preference to a business from out of state.
Correct.
I guess what I heard was that our existing in-state businesses would like to see preference given to them, as you might have.
THAT OUR EXISTING IN-STATE BUSINESSES WOULD LIKE TO SEE PREFERENCE GIVEN TO THEM AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE OVER EXISTING BUSINESSES FROM OTHER STATES.
Yep.
So I'm going to ignore the tax one, the fee charge for right now, and that is pretty much either a yes or a no.
That moves down.
The next part of the language again.
tax one the fee charge for right now and that is pretty much either a yes or a no um that moved down the next part of the language again is you're looking at considering the intent of the bill in 2026 will be to legalize two outs we just want to decriminalize up to that amount um temporarily until the legalization.
Correct.
And then the, uh, so the question about this, uh, in, in the car.
Um, that I, I did some homework on.
The open container statute um and so the open container statute um has an exemption um and that is a not a person's transporting carrying possessing or having any liquor or beverage in a chartered bus taxi limousine for hire provided however the driver of any said vehicle is prohibited from having any liquor or beverage in or around the driver's area so in terms of lifting that section, and then the other thing, the piece that I just heard today was if if.
The passenger, not the driver, if the passenger happens to be a carrier card, carrying medical.
medical exemption person should they also have the happens to be a carrier card carrying medical.
Exemption person should they also have the right to be able to take a edible?
Obviously, they can't smoke it in the car because that would be distracting to the driver.
Um, you have an edible that they could if they needed to in that emergency situation.
And so you guys want to go talk about it?
Well, I have a question.
Yep.
So thank you.
I just want to, again, working from the amendment, on line 10, it says the laws of the state of New Hampshire or second another state.
So I understand by saying second, it is lowering in priority someone who has cannabis experience in another state as opposed to the ATCs operating in New Hampshire.
Am I reading that correctly?
That was my intention, yes.
Okay.
I would say that I did have a conversation with the liquor commissioner, and he said that when you apply an application, they have a scoring system.
And he recommended that we might consider that anyone who is currently in ATC would get a bonus 15 points before the rest of the application is considered as a way to address that issue.
Through rules or with this language?
I would say we would put it in the statute.
Yeah language would allow that no I'm saying that I'm not sure this language would allow that that be interpreted that but that if we wanted to clarify what's the language that you guys put in which is that previous marijuana experience you know uh I we could do it uh when we write the blurb i've done that before that in the blurb saying that what the what the legislative intent is of that concept is is that or we can write it in statue or we could just uh you know give guidance that yes that when they do rulemaking for that application that the implication is that favoritism is by adding uh points scoring yeah i i think it would be hard i i'm not sure that we can put it in statute i'm totally open to working that out because i do understand that um just as we recognized in the senate version uh in some of the work we did in the Senate to talk, to recognize the importance of recognizing New Hampshire farmers, we want to recognize New Hampshire businesses and New Hampshire ATCs.
I don't know that we actually know what the application or the point system will be, so it may be difficult to do in legislation, but I'm open to working through that.
Right, and I would remind you that this really is only an ATC problem because we have no limit on licensures for cultivators.
Maybe you hadn't thought of that.
The intent of that segment is strictly all things being equal between an in-state and out-of-state you give preference to the end state right so that would be a simple one but he was saying if you wanted to how how a good way to do it is to simply say not just in-state out-of-state because who knows somebody out with some other of, because you just simply said that had this marijuana experience and we're assuming that the only people who have marijuana experience is the ATCs.
But he was saying is if you really wanted to be much more direct, then you would just spell it out to say they get an extra 15 points scoring or extra scoring or something that along that line that would give them a heads up and i did discuss this with the atcs and they are they they are positive about that approach can we look at page 5 section section 37?
Are there you'd best describe to us in excruciating detail any changes that have been made in effective dates?
So what line are we in?
I'm sorry, my room in rules takes me a little little moment.
Starting on number seven, right?
So what sections did you leave in?
What did you take out?
We're working from the Senate version.
Did you make any changes to any effective dates other than the decrim?
The decrim is, at this point, that's the only thing we're discussing, yeah.
I did not hear anybody else mentioning any other date changes.
I guess speak now forevermore.
So, Pete, Jason, on your section on effective date 37, is there any difference in which portions of this bill we put off and which ones were acting immediately from the Senate version.
Everything remains the same other than that 6, 7, 8.
And that's all the proposal on Decret.
Okay.
My last question is simply as I'm reading this, I see the change in the tax from 15 to 12 and a half.
There's no change.
There is no accommodation for therapeutic cannabis to not be taxed in any of this.
No change.
Thank you.
no change i'm gonna probably take a break so the seneca caucus and chat i doubt well i think it's going to take more than just a break coming back in 10 minutes so i suggest that we establish a recess sometime okay Okay.
So, we're talking about the 5th.
I do have 1 p.m.
Yes, I have that available.
No, I'm, I'm, yes, everybody.
Okay, yeah, okay.
I was just, yes, everybody is free to speak.
I'm good.
You never had a trouble speaking up before.
Okay.
We're going to do tomorrow at 1 p.m.
Do you have extra copies of your amendment?
Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
say that again.
Let's go back to my office right now.
This is just the transporting.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
No, it was a side by side.
So yes, it was a side by side.
So, yes, it is.
Okay.
We will recess.
The media conference on HB.
1366 till tomorrow at 1 PM.
1631 do I have.
1633.
The cannabis P.
I told you that I don't I don't remember.
Charlie.
Okay.
Thank you.
you well okay Okay, community conference.
If it's Tuesday, it must be 12.
Don't.
This is 1018.
Okay.
1018.
Oh, yeah, because I put a pencil mark to it.
Okay, 1018.
Relative on-premise, off-premise liquor licenses in relative land in current use.
So this is the one that has something about...
Current use is a misleading thing, but it just happens to be the statute.
It was, this is about protecting our border border so you want to tell us about this it allows people to post their land with the six um activities outlined in the bill um also land for no trespass for skiing, snowshoeing, fishing, hunting, hiking, or nature observation without losing their special discount for current use.
And then, obviously, if somebody is trespassing, it would enable local law enforcement to arrest somebody for trespass.
So that's the premise of the bill.
And I believe the House actually passed that bill, and you added the House version of bail fixes, 318, which is having a committee, a conference tomorrow.
Right.
So we non-concurred with that, knowing the House had passed bail.
And so we attached it to, we attached 504, Senate Bill 504 to 1018.
Don't think there's any problem with 1018.
And based on your earlier vote on Senate Bill 504, I don't think there's any problem with that either.
So you're saying with current use, because I have land in current use.
Yes.
And my land just has specific things that I posted for, right?
You can, under the current law, you can post it.
Okay.
For those six things that I just read.
These say you can't do them.
And still receive.
Right.
So right now, my sign says no snowmobiles, no dirt bikes, no hunting, no firearms.
Do you get an extra?
And I absolutely have my land in current use okay but do you get the extra discount because the extra discount allows um recreational activities on that land and no trespass except for skiing snowsho hunting, hiking, or nature observation.
That's the current law now.
All this does is allow somebody to post their land and retain the extra discount.
Those six things would not constitute trespass.
How much of a discount do you get over or above it?
20%.
It's over.
Right now I pay like on a 200 acre piece.
I only paid $120 or something.
Nothing.
I think for larger pieces of property that are like timber concerns and things like that in the North country, it's probably a little bit more money than what you're paying for 200 acres.
Okay.
So I got you.
I mean, the Forest Society, not the Forest Society, the Farm Bureau and the Jason Scott, his guys, came into the Senate hearing, asked for us to amend the bill to ensure that um it would not impact the 20 discount for people those people who yeah so i and the house passed that as i recall i'd have to pull it up um but it did so why did you attach it to one of our bills what was because when you passed it you attached your version of bail no not not me not commerce the house no not why did you just attach it to judiciary bills why would you why would you want to make my life miserable John why would you make my life miserable over some of your bills I didn't touch any on Jermaine amendments.
We've become best friends again.
Yes, we have.
And you reminded me, we came into the house together.
That's right.
1990.
And we both were, Sierra Club, we got Sierra Club lifetime memberships because we both had perfect voting records that year.
Yeah, that year.
Now we have gray hair.
That ain't happening probably ever again.
So, okay.
Representative Hammond.
So I just want to understand the concept here.
a landowner can post no trespassing sign and not receive a discount, right?
They lose the discount.
That's my understanding.
So in order to receive the extra discount, this would allow them to post for no trespass except for those six activities.
And the language of the sign is prescribed by statute here.
they'd have to put that that doesn't change okay and so this would open up more land for these six things skiing snow showing it would allow property owners who want to avail themselves of the discount to be able to post their land for uh no trespass except for those six activities and then um you know along the northern border when people were interdicted they could be interdicted for trespass what if they were nature observing if they were doing any of those activities there'd be a presumption of no problem Okay.
Representative Burrows.
Yes.
I was wondering how this bill would impact the um enforcement on the border for illegal crossings.
How would this impact that?
So if somebody were to be detained for trespass, then if they were not in this country with proper documentation, they could be detained.
Where currently, right now, my understanding is they couldn't be detained.
So this was a request of the attorney general to me, which is why I sponsored the bill.
So if somebody, just to understand, somebody's hiking, you know, with these signs, they're hiking, and would law enforcement be able to question them if they suspect that they're, they're here illegally.
Uh, yeah, I would assume so.
So again, I'm looking at the house.
Um, docket.
What passed 17 to nothing in the committee report and I assume it was.
Thank you.
I can't remember which committee criminal justice.
And then the committee report was on to pass and it went to the floor and was passed on the voicemail on.
You know, I did talk to Chairman Roy Roy and he did say to me that that.
They were okay with this amendment.
Okay, look, I read the Senate report.
Okay.
And there was a lot of discussion in the Senate report about illegal crossings and about data and whatnot.
So I guess I'm still trying to connect the dots between that and this bill why there was so much discussion about that in the Senate hearing.
Because currently my understanding is you could not.
Tain somebody for trespass in those circumstances.
And so it just leaves a vulnerability on the northern border, much of which is very remote and very easy to cross.
So there you have it.
So I'm still trying to point my finger how this bill is going to work to prevent illegal crossings.
Why this specific bill?
Because at least there would be a possibility that somebody could be detained.
Right now, my understanding is that is not the case.
Well, how do you determine if somebody might be illegal?
For example, I live on the National Forest.
I live in the North.
I have a stepson who's actually, he's born and bred in New Hampshire.
He's very dark-skinned, just how he is.
Why would he maybe possibly not be detained if he was hiking in the northern country because he was dark-skinned?
He was hiking.
I don't think anybody would be detained that had any kind of documentation.
So I think it's for people without...
But would he be singled out because maybe he was dark skin and they might say, well, this guy may not be, might not be American.
How do, I guess I would answer it this way.
How does law enforcement ever have probable cause?
Thank you very much to stop anybody i mean it you're doing something generally speaking that law enforcement whether it's speeding whether it's some other kind of behavior that creates a presumption and then you can be asked and stopped and released or not released.
I'm just concerned that this is going to be used as an excuse to potentially harass people who, you know, look like they might be from another country.
I mean, my stepson looks like he could be from Mexico, Saudi Arabia, a lot of different countries, and he's all American.
But does he go hiking without his wallet, without his driver's license?
Oh, yeah.
Particularly where we live absolutely goes without his license and all that.
Yeah, he does.
Does he drive in a car to get to that spot?
To my house?
Yeah, and we go from my house.
He doesn't need his wallet to leave our house.
well, I guess if he's of a certain olive skin, maybe that's a good idea to have a wallet with him.
Oh, John, you don't want to say that.
Well, I'm saying that's what you're implying.
If you're a citizen within the United States, you're not supposed to have to require to walk around with documentation unless you're driving a car.
If you're just hiking in the woods, you're not supposed to have to have anything as a legal resident.
Right.
But if you were happen to be walking around the National Forest on the on our state on the capital line on the US line, you don't think that maybe it's a good idea.
I mean, I'm not expecting you to carry your passport with you but wouldn't you have your wallet with you so that in case you you want to stop at a store and buy a beer i never have my wallet i don't okay all right so let's just say it's true so you're saying that no person that if a person is stopped and clearly does not look like they're camping they've got something backs backside.
You're saying that someone could potentially be lightly dressed, doesn't look like they're spending overnight anywhere, they just happen to be crossing the border, and you think a cop isn't going to say, well, gee, you don't look like a camper to me.
Well, I guess the other question is why, you know, again, I'm reading that testimony.
There was no, I didn't get a clear answer when people were asking about the stats on the northern border about people coming in.
And I'm reading a report here that there were something like 21 people coming through over like a two-year period.
So why, I guess, why this those stats are totally misleading okay having been any stats on the report having i get that okay but if you've gone to pittsburgh like i did okay and several of our colleagues in the senate and you've actually driven out along what's called Hall Streams Road, Hall Stream Road, which is a seven-mile-long dirt road right on the border between Canada and the United States.
And you see a stream that's maybe three times as wide as this table, and probably about that deep.
And how remote it it is getting any law enforcement there with any kind of alacrity is almost impossible and the people we met at a farm up there owned by a gentleman keith robinson and they have seen people they have seen signs of people that have left markers in the road that then come out of the forest, get in a car, drive away, and they're gone.
So the fact that the law enforcement capability up there is so slim that you have to drive 35 to 40 minutes to get there.
That's why the statistics are the way they are.
It's very, very misleading.
If I could say further.
I have been there.
I did not get to go with the Senate a couple weeks ago.
But I've been there.
i do work up at all the schools in the north and i do pittsburgh elementary school i'm replacing their curtains and the music teacher there said would you like to meet my husband he's a border patrol agent i said i'd love to meet your husband and he told me about the 7 000 encounters they've had in the squantum section and he said yes we may only have 21 people that we caught but he said the signs of other people there's like canoes all over the place left when they're crossing he said we only have caught 21 how many have got away because we we don't have the enforcement capabilities at the time we don't have the personnel he estimates it's far in excess of that 21 low number that they've used so again there's 7 000 that we know in the area of ma Maine, New Hampshire, and Vermont called the Squantum region.
7,000?
Could you explain that?
Where's that number from?
7,000 interactions.
CPB, Customs and Border Patrol, in the Squantum sector, which goes from the main border to somewhere in upstate New York.
So it's, I think, about a 250 mile, um, segment 50 miles roughly is in New Hampshire, obviously some of Vermont and then some in New Hampshire and border apprehensions this year alone, when we were up there were over 7,000 in the first, I think it was seven months of the fiscal year.
And that exceeded or will exceed the 7,000 that were apprehended last year, according to Customs and Border Patrol stat.
So the problem's real, even though the northern border is incredibly porous, has minimal resources.
I'm working to try to get a grant for communications that should have been funded through the Northern Border, whatever it's called, the Northern Border Program, federal funds, and wasn't, so that law enforcement can even have basic communication with each other.
There's next to no email or cell service um up there so you've got a problem that is wide open and people are crossing that border and so this i'm not going to sit here and say this will solve the problem it won't solve the problem it's just one tool in the arsenal we this is the whole justification for the 1.4 million dollars in the budget last year to enhance local law enforcement they feel it is working and that um we need to continue it um you know so i i again i i think this is just common sense one more word it'll be very quick so you were talking about i think your son who's brown skinned i have a nephew and niece and they do hike and they are both korean born um so i share your concern but the border patrol agents that i met are only looking to like anything there could be a bad you know there's a bad cop somewhere.
But overall, I trust in our law enforcement.
And if you give articulatable reasons that, you know, my car is down here, my license is there, or it's at my house, and you say, I'm Bill Gannon, I live in X location, these are reasonable people, and they're not looking to bother anyone else.
But if they interdict someone, they find out there's a detainer notice against the person.
We want to make a phone call to either the next to Homeland or ICE.
We want to make a phone call to either the next to Homeland or ICE and continue to lie.
If they meet your son or my niece or nephew, they're going to say where they live and they're going to let them right go.
Representative Spear.
I if I if I can understand this properly correctly.
So a person trespasses based on the definition that's in this bill, that somebody trespasses.
And you mentioned also, it was mentioned that law enforcement might be 35 miles away or maybe it was 35 minutes away.
I don't remember which one you said.
Is that person supposed to detain somebody?
What is supposed to happen there?
Remember, this is a comment that River is bringing up about if that possibility could occur.
In other words, somebody has dropped a dime and told the cop to come up there because there's somebody looking suspicious or something is tromping around in the woods.
Because I'm pretty sure that these Border Patrol guys, if they're anywhere, they're in the swath.
That's not the case I'm talking about.
45 minutes, within 45 minutes to get a cop up there, whoever that person is that's trespassing is gone.
Anyways.
Probably gone.
Right.
Or do we expect some landowner to shoot him in the head?
What is supposed to happen?
What is the thing that's supposed to happen in that 45 minutes?
You're bringing up a good question because I'm sitting here trying to follow myself because I do own a square mile and I do have it posted.
Okay.
posted.
And the idea that I have it posted is because I'm serious about what I don't want.
I don't want dirt bikes and snowmobile.
Snowmobile problem.
So I have my property posted.
What I'm just finding out is that some people could not get the benefit that I get, which is this current use credit that really is almost everything.
I mean, I literally pay nothing.
So I guess to me, the issue here is that this whole idea of trafficking of people or people coming across the board is somewhat of a red herring.
To me, this bill really, in my mind, is about how we want to ensure that landowners who post their land don't lose out on that benefit.
And that's why at this point, I'm just assumed vote for this to allow it on because it did pass the House.
Like you say, the chairman Roy said it was going to pass.
It's attached to a bill that we know has been problematic and probably will die anyways.
But at this point, I just think this whole issue about  last I heard, they only said like 19 people have come across the border.
Now, I know that you say there's 7,000 interactions, but that is, to me, people coming across the border, coming down.
That is the least of my worries here in New Hampshire.
I just  I mean I know maybe the governor or maybe other people are worried about it, but it's such a long way to get down from that border, let alone the Canadian side just to get down there.
So I just  I'm more interested in making sure that these people don't lose out on their tax credit.
I absolutely agree with that.
No problem.
Got that.
Great.
I am concerned about what is your thought about, let's say you found somebody trespassing on your property.
You call the police, but you live someplace close where there's a policeman.
What do they do up north?
I assume they call the Pittsburgh police.
Do they capture and put them in a garage?
What do they do?
Well, I mean, is Pittsburgh 3,000?
Otherwise, you'd call a state trooper.
And you just wait 45 minutes and hope the guy stays around.
This bill won't change that.
That's all I want to know.
That bill doesn't do anything to that.
That's not changing.
Exactly.
You would have an opportunity to detain somebody that was suspected of crossing the border illegally before trespassing and still allow an owner to post his or her land for those six activities and retain their discount so i'm okay with.
You really want to be replaced?
Yeah, I do.
Chris, how do you feel about this?
You live on the North.
Okay.
Really need to you haven't been to this.
You want to reply?
How do you feel about this amendment all of it that much okay well one's for it the other one's against it okay well it doesn't matter if we're going to replace it doesn't you know it could be anybody okay but Okay.
But you really want to be replaced.
I'm concerned about profile.
Okay.
I know you've expressed that before and other issues and.
And that's fine.
You're entitled to your opinion.
Okay.
All right.
Is there some way we can work this out?
Can we talk for a second?
Okay, let's go to my office.
John, I will.
John.
Thank you.
So we have a full contingent, right?
All right.
So I'll make a motion to the house will accede to the Senate position.
All those in favor, please raise their hand.
One, two, three, four.
Wait a minute.
What is the motion?
Pass it.
We're going to pass this.
Cede.
Just pass it.
Okay.
Five.
Those opposed?
One, two.
Okay.
There we are.
obviously, for this bill to go further, it will have require some replacements.
Okay, that will end the committee conference on House Bill 1018.
Thank you.
All right.
all right um we'll let's see how we're gonna handle this one okay why don't we start with the conversation about the uh ticket resellers which is um what's uh what section in the bill okay Okay.
So, Senator Shanley brought this board and it meant overwhelming support.
It was 20.0.
That's not total.
In our state, we've had a lot of problems, especially with the smaller theater venues, with people abusing ticket sales.
They go to a site, like the Palace Theater test extends the problem.
And people have minutes of AI-looking sites that looks like you're buying from the palace.
You think you're taking your granddaughter to Snow White and, oh, who's big?
Taylor Swift, somebody.
And you're going there for your Taylor Swift ticket, you can see 160 and think, well, that won't be the price.
I'm going to go front and center.
Then you go to the palace theater and they've sold you tickets that, A, they didn't have, B, b don't exist and so people are getting ripped off left and right in new hampshire at all types of venues so down to shamley has been championing this building for several years and so i do appreciate her stance on the bill and think that it's time we do something about it i do realize the difficulty of getting out of state people or people from other countries who have these sites but i would at least appreciate our trying to go after people who are violating these laws in state because the palace theater has had hundreds of people show up with tickets that don't exist or were sold and people who paid quadruple the face value when there were other tickets for sale because they think they went to the actual site and they have in fact been at a artificial site so we would like john for this to go through i if if at all possible i do understand you're saying how are we going to get people in Singapore who have fake sites but because we have a limited opportunity to get people out of state I do appreciate it but at least we could get the ones who are operating in state as a start would be our position do you have anything else to say thank you um I just note that this section starts on page 33 line 17 at section 6.
if you're looking for it it comes after the long money transmitter piece so page so i'm not saying this 33 dying the sword for this but i don't think it would be a bad thing i think it would be in fact a good thing if we put this along with this other legislation.
I have a question on that.
Yep.
Go ahead.
Ken, could you remind me, is there been money allocated to follow up on people who are breaking this law in New Hampshire for enforcement?
Or is it needed?
So, um, House Bill 2 funded a cyber security unit in the Consumer Protection Bureau starting this July 1st by letting them keep um an extra i think 500 000 a year to hire an attorney an investigator and a paralegal so there will be resources for cyber crimes um starting starting July 1st of this year.
So, Mr.
chair, if if your body would favor.
Would like to keep it in.
Yeah.
And if so, if you could pull your members and see if they like this or not.
Well, let's get all the issues on the table and then we'll have our discussion okay so um we actually had a very similar bill in the committee and um and we we did not pass it uh and the concern was that actually it was ironic remember representative gives who pointed out that this might happen sometimes on tickets Calvary but that really happens a lot on hotels that you know bookings.com people always seem to hit the wrong wrong page and and uh so it's obviously um this is this is not not just limited to ticket resales.
This is a huge problem in anything that people may desire that's on the Internet.
So in terms of how far are we going to go and what we're going to expect.
When I first got the bill, I immediately pulled up on my computer at the Palace Theater.
I typed in the Palace Theater.
And the very first link was, I don't know, I don't remember the name.
It was some ticket.
And so then I'm taking the language of this bill.
And looking at their web page.
And marvelous lead that they were actually already in compliance.
And what the, they started out with.
Okay, so no, they don't have the classic palace theater logo, which looks sort of like a little, I guess it's the marquee.
And they don't have the marquee, but they did is they have the marquee, but they cut off the bottom of the picture.
So it just says PLA, you see, and then they stopped.
And then then you go through and then they definitely identify and say that they were not affiliated with any theater, that they are here to provide a service to you to buy the ticket so that that disclosure.
So all those other issues, it seemed like they were right.
So then I said, well, let's go pick a seat and let's compare pricing.
And sure enough, this webpage, the pricing was definitely higher, almost double.
But you know what really got me was how did they know that J2 through five or j1 through four were available are they updating their web page or how they're doing it or how is it that this reseller knows this information and uh i mean how could they do live or on and then i know that that was some of the concern we had heard about the issue going forward.
They sell you the ticket and then they go buy it.
Then they go.
But that's what we had heard back.
That's what we had heard the last time.
So maybe that was true.
But they would seem to have the ones that were sold on the other page did have it.
So they must update it.
I mean, it's obviously there's a lot of people spending a lot of time and effort making this to work.
But at the end of the day, it's, you know, this is the reason why I believe the committee killed it was it was a buyer beware.
The buyer needs to know that you've got to go to the right webpage to get something.
Okay.
So we just found that we had a lot of people who come to us say they've done this, especially with this Palace Theater.
There are other Thank you.
the right web page to get something okay so we just found it we had a lot of people who come to us say they've done this especially with this palace theater there are other places also right so i realize that this is a big net you talked about out of country people we wouldn't be able to reach them and stuff i do see those so there's a net here we're not going to catch everybody but um as a famous politician said who was sitting here momentarily right don't look He always said, do not  yeah, don't let the  The perfect be  yes, I've heard the expression.
The perfect be the enemy of the good.
Right, but in my case, I don't like passing, let's say, to feel good, it's on the books, and people are going to be greatly disappointed that  because at the end of the day, act was written the purpose of the consumer protection act was to protect consumers from in-state businesses that um that do not refund people's money that that was the purpose of it and so to have the state you know the attorney general's office worrying about you know live nation all over you know whenever and all these all of these ticket issues um it seems like it would be a wild goose chase and and also a real waste of resources for what we right now the attorney general consumer protection is pretty stretched i understand I'm not too excited.
I knew where we were Protection is pretty stretched.
I understand your position.
I'm not too excited about that.
I knew where we were going when we started with this.
All right.
So that is Section 6 of the bill.
The next issue is Section 7 and 8, I believe, and 9.
Is that also eight seven eight nine is that is that right ryan seven eight nine it would be your if you go farther seven eight nine and ten okay I am I am on page 34.
That starts on page.
Yeah, that's the wrong 1.
I did.
I just give you the new 1.
that's that's 1.
I want to look at one that says Senate on the top.
Okay, here's 1.
Okay, so.
As a co sponsor of this legislation, I certainly wanted to give at least some stab at trying to survive it.
This is the 1.
represent grassy who sits on yeah the committee and the issue was um the i'm getting these um basically this is an investment feature for cities towns and counties and that um they invest it and um it was kind of annoying to some people that they don't put money in New Hampshire banks.
You know, this is to him, you know, cities and towns, why wouldn't they want to?
Well, I guess they get higher interest rates.
With say, so the amendment that we've just been passed around.
Is simply to to take out the offending language, which was maintain no less than 30%.
We would delete that and just make it a feel good.
statement committee shall strive to okay okay so that this amendment as you see here where you see the the 30 we're just crossing that out okay very much there you go i think it's uh holding back and i i've got a couple letters on this yeah put your mic on.
I've gotten a couple of letters on this.
Yeah.
Put your mic on.
I have gotten a couple of letters on this.
I just talked to Dave Caron from Dairy, who's the  and he said that on average, there's about a 50 basis point difference between what PDIP is offering and what banks are.
It ranges anywhere from 75 basis points down to 15, but that's what he's saying.
A study came out by Brian Gottlieb, who just made a few phone calls and determined that that's not the case.
Ouch.
I'm sure his research was a little more than a few phone calls.
And what I'm also assured of is that on the PDIP website, they mentioned that there is risk involved, which I think that should be said because I think it is more risky than a Fed-backed CD.
But I think that's okay.
I think for an extra 50 basis points, it's worth it.
Right.
So in this case, all we're saying is that PDAP at least consider the bank and just consider it.
That's all it is.
It's feel good now, just at least consider it.
And it's under review by the state treasurer anyways and anyways so uh I think there's uh a lot of uh good strong feelings about it and we don't need this language okay so you're okay with this amendment yes okay are you guys okay with this amendment we'll be okay personally I'm not because I don't think if you put any number to strive for it's just feel good legislation which you usually don't like you're usually saying why am i going to pass feel good legislation and i feel like we're doing that right now but that's okay we're in the committee conference and so so it's fine we're feeling so good and i feel like it gives the state treasurer more nimbleness to be able to react to market conditions.
If things change and the manager wants to put more or less money into banks, then the banks that have a presence in New Hampshire.
And you referenced the statute.
I passed it out.
It's 6-8 Roman 1 and Roman 1A.
It's basically federal banks, banks that are chartered here and banks chartered in another state that have a presence here and engage in lending activity in state to the extent they have deposits.
So to me, it's an economic stimulus piece.
And I think this is a real compromise from where the Senate started out.
And I'm a middle child.
So I don't fear compromise.
You'd be surprised how many middle childs are politicians.
We make better legislators, but personally I'm paid.
I'm the youngest.
I just want my way.
There you go.
But we're fine.
But I appreciate your work on this, Mr.
Chairman.
Okay.
Okay, so we haven't really caucused, but I mean, I feel like if we pass the underlying bill, we delete out the ticket reselling section and pass this amendment.
Okay, everybody okay for that?
Okay.
So all those to a seed to this Senate position.
With amendments to remove section, what did I call say section 6 that I say.
No, wait a minute.
Uh, wait a minute.
The section.
No, that.
say section 6 did i say from page 34.
no wait a minute uh wait a minute the yeah section no that where am i yeah section 6 on 33.
and amend uh And amend section investment advisor.
That's 2A.
So amend section 8.
And for those of you falling at home, is that correct?
Okay, that's my motion.
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
All those opposed.
So moved unanimously.
Okay, great.
Thank you.
Sorry to drag it through the ticket thing.
Okay.
This is the fund currently.
It was established in 2016 with 276 million in settlement funds from Exxon Mobil.
From what?
Exxon Mobil.
Okay.
Thank you.
Well, we don't have language, but we can  I think we have an idea of what we're talking about now, is that the Senate  we have to accede to the House position, but with another amendment, and the language of that amendment was what was passed in House Bill  What was the number?
House Bill 393.
Okay, so basically the House Finance did pass the bill, 393, with only the money for the study, which was only $2 million.
For the engineering.
For the engineering, $2 million for the engineering.
$4.5 million, I believe.
$6.5 million altogether.
Okay.
So, we are going to take what the House passed out of finance.
$6.5 million.
That's the $6.5 million.
And we're going to add that to  that's already done.
Right.
It's already passed.
Yes.
So, it's already passed so you're just a cd to the house position and we're done we're just clarifying yes that's what we were even better that's what we just needed the moment to clarify one for us that you're cd to the house position that whole issue with the 25 million was dealt with it's all been dealt with in 393 perfect that's music my ears there'll be another bill next year for the remainder so all we need to focus on is the 1259 languages it came over from the house edition yes yes okay so i make a motion that we accede to the house position is the question clear all those in favor.
Please say aye aye.
Aye.
Those opposed.
So moved unanimously and we're all set.
Very good.
Well, thanks.
I'm glad you were here.
Donna.
I would have had to explain the whole thing.
Thank you.